so what are you hungry okay so this is
for you it's a piece of Ross selenite oh
I love you you know it's a little bit
like gypsum they're kind of the same
thing but they form different
so this refract light in a really cool
way yes what kind of if you look and you
hold it like that you can see how that
kind of shimmers yes surface of that
it's really cool I really like really
into just I usually I actually weren't
today but I I have a honey quartz that I
wear and quartz necklace that I wear all
the time because it's a very it's a very
powerful stone quartz beautiful yeah and
in this they say that you yeah under the
light of a full moon and like those
aren't was that in the Sun yeah they
were charged yes it was really be I am a
nerd with you Sheldon I was I was trying
to pick up something as beautiful as you
I don't think I did you justice oh my
gosh I love you oh my god I needed to
hear that you're so kind I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this